welcome back to CBS this morning we are
seeing new video this morning of a mod
our Barry the unarmed black man in
Georgia who was chased shot and killed
in February while jogging in the
neighborhood Britain's Guardian website
has uncovered police body cam footage
from November of 2017 now it reveals a
previous encounter between our Barry and
two officers his family lawyers say that
this raises more questions about the
local police department's conduct Omar
Villafranca is following this story for
us body cam footage from 2017 first
obtained by the Guardian shows a Glenn
County police officer approached ahmad
armory in a Brunswick Georgia park as
the officer returns from running our
burries license a mod appears to be
upset I'll tell you why I'm here man
I'll tell you why because this area is
known for drug activity I'm not
searching you I'm checking you for
weapons all right man less than two
minutes later another officer appears an
armory refuses to let them search his
car the second officer then orders our
burry to the ground after he fires his
taser but it malfunctions and doesn't
shock our brave entually they let our
burry go and he walks away more than two
years later our burry would be killed by
father and son Gregory and Travis
McMichael while on a run neither
McMichael was a Glenn County police
officer but they suspected our burry was
burglarizing a construction site in
their neighborhood the property owner
says our burry took nothing and
surveillance footage shows multiple
people walking in the handling of our
buries case has drawn widespread
scrutiny the McMichaels were arrested
months after his death a judge outside
the circuit where our burry was shot is
now handling the case after five others
recused themselves and three District
Attorney's have passed on prosecuting it
statement our breeze family attorneys
told us about the body cam footage quote
it appears to be just a glimpse into the
kind of scrutiny a Matar buri face not
only by this police department but
ultimately regular citizens like to
McMichaels we also reached out to the
Glenn County Police Department for a
statement but did not hear back Tony all
right Omar thank you very much